[Applause]
it's good to be back this is uh first of
all i mean i got to mention you
we'll talk about you you were an intern
here at the show yeah the cage was right
over there yeah
five years ago you were and this is what
happens when people intern on our show
they all become
get your applications in yeah thanks a
lot yeah yeah the money's good when
you're an intern it is did you have a
good time when you're an intern on the
show i had a blast
i uh my job is actually to just hang out
backstage with you just before you went
on
and you'd run through some monologue
jokes they always have a that's funny
they always have we always have a few
interns back there just to let them see
what how it goes
back there yeah and there was uh one
monologue joke that i remember so well
and uh you were extremely funny but the
joke was uh pap buchanan
had uh his kidney stones removed last
week and he knew about them for a while
but he just found out that the two
kidney stones were gay
and i thought that was the funniest
thing i'd ever seen so i started
laughing and laughing and you were like
do you think that's funny and i said
yeah and you were like no you don't
all you kids do all you kids do is go
home and smoke pot and listen to pearl
jams
[Applause]
you didn't know that i'm 64 years old oh
yeah that's me that's me a beautiful one
yeah it's beautiful
it's very nice let's talk about this is
first of all we're all very happy for
you you've done
you've done so well and uh and i think
one of the hardest parts of your job now
in the office
is you work with mr carrell and he's
such a funny guy and we've had him here
on the show but
he's he's so funny how do you how do you
not laugh when you're working with him
because you have to say
stay straight yeah the simple answer to
that is you don't you break all the time
he's nothing without writers but
once he gets going no once
the sad thing is now that we're in our
second season he knows exactly how to
get us
right right and so he does this thing
where every time he gets slightly
emotional
i i just lose it and so there was this
one scene where he asked me to help him
and i didn't really want to help him and
he says you know i i really have it
tough and you know everybody in this
office
you know you think santa has it tough
but santa has elves okay
and uh and no one is elving me and
i think i was under the desk at that
point
yeah yeah yeah it would be and so you
get to also there's some ad libbing
obviously going on
yeah you just hold on for dear life and
try not to laugh
now we actually we come from uh similar
oh pretty much the same place i'm from
brookline you're from newton
massachusetts
from newton mass so we're like grew up
yeah
that's right they're not from there they
just want to listen to their applause
yeah we're i'm i'm from right around you
i've actually seen you walking your dog
on the holidays
what oh yeah really you see me were you
like following me in some pervy way
there he is yeah no we're
hey no i i would never stop you because
you
look like you're having such a good time
and i didn't want you to start running
like i'm like
was i alone no you're with your dog
hudson
how do you know my dog's name
likes is dog food
probably at 6 15 p.m yeah well this is
all true everything you've said that's
very eerie
do you go back to massachusetts much i
do i go back a lot i was actually just
there a couple days ago i just had a
niece
uh and so no applause to hell with
babies
that was weird isn't that weird they
applauded the they plotted newton mass
then you said
uh i just had a niece nothing from us
bring up newton again yeah exactly so i
was back there and i was at south
station looking at the
the board that ticks over to tell you
what track you're on and some guy
and this is great because boston always
keeps you humble and this guy was uh
just i don't know just great
stereotypical uh boston guy and he says
john
john from the office and i go yeah and
he's like love the show funny show on
television
and i was like oh thank you so much and
i was about to like go over and say
thank you for
and he's like yeah okay take care
i almost missed my train take care buddy
all right that's enough that's easy
there
stalker weirdo
that is so true because uh i when i go
back this they always sort of
let you know you had they don't get too
big on yourself there
i went i i remember go flying into logan
airport not too long ago it was like a
year ago and i literally just walked out
of the airport
and just got like to within i wasn't
even gonna get in the cab lines my
brother was picking up but i walked out
of the airport and i just sort of
was walking around you just walk out and
i got to near the front of the cab line
and this guy was like hey hey hey here
tv stop get to the back of the line
i think that was my dad yeah that was
probably yeah said how's your dog hudson
oh man they let you know